رجحت الاستخبارات الامريكيه انخفاض وتيره
القتال في اوكرانيا خلال الاشهر المقبله
وقالت مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه
الامريكيه ايفر الهندس ان السؤال يبقى
مطروحا بشان مستقبل الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا بعد فصل الشتاء في الاثناء دعا
رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون لمنح روسيا
ضمانات الامنيه لقاء عودتها الى التفاوض
بشان انهاء الصراع
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي المؤشرات
الميدانيه والسياسيه التي دفعت
الاستخبارات الامريكيه للترجيح انخفاض
وتيره القتال في اوكرانيا خلال الاشهر
المقبله
الامريكيه ودعوه ماكرون الى منح روسيا
ضمانات امنيه في حال عادت الى التفاوض وهل
هي دعوه اوروبيه صرفه ام غربيه تحل على
بعد عام كيف استقبلت موسكو هذه الرسائل
وهل تشكل الضمانات الامنيه لروسيا عرضا
كافيا يمكن ان يدفع الاطراف الى الجلوس
على طويله المفاوضات وانها الصراع
[موسيقى]
بينما تستمر الاعمال القتاليه بين الجيشين
الروسي والاوكراني ترصد الاستخبارات
الامريكيه مؤشرات اخرى وتبني عليها وترجيح
المفادو بان وتيره القتال مقبله على
التباطؤ في المستقبل ترجيح السند الى
معطيات من بينها ما سيفرضه الشتاء المقبل
من بيئه مختلفه للصراع يتساءل مراقبون عن
مدى امكانيه ربطه بدعوه الرئيس الفرنسيه
لمنح روسيا ضمانات امنيه ان هي قبلت
التفاوض بشان انهاء الصراع الدائري في
اوكرانيا فهل تتظافر الجهود السياسيه مع
مقتضيات المناخ لتصنع مرحله اخرى نشهد
فيها راحه الحرب وقد خففت من وطاتها نتابع
مقالته مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه
ممكن
في الوقت الحالي حول بخموت ومنطقه دونيتس
قد تباط نوعا ما مع انسحاب روسيا من منطقه
خرسون الغربيه الى الشرق من النهر ونتوقع
استمرار ذلك في الاشهر المقبله ايضا بعد
ذلك وبمجرد تجاوز فصل الشتاء فان السؤال
المطروح هو كيف سيبدو الهجوم المضاد
المحتمل في الربيع في مارس وفي تلك
المنطقه نتوقع صراحه ان يكون كلا الجيشين
في وضع يتطلعان فيه الى محاوله التجهيز
واعاده الامداد بمعنى اعاده التشكيل حيث
يكونان مستعدين نوعا ما لهذا الهجوم
المضاد
الرئيس الفرنسيه
في الساحه الروسيه داعيا الى منحي موسكو
ضمانات امنيه ان هي عاده الى التفاوض ما
الذي قاله الرئيس الفرنسي
الى بوابات روسيا هذا الموضوع سيكون جزءا
من المواضيع المتعلقه باحلال السلام
وبالتالي وجب التحضير لما نحن مستعدون
لفعله وكيف سنحمله والدول الاعضاء عبر
اعطاء ضمانات لروسيا تتعلق باملها حين
تعود الى طاوله المفاوضات
[موسيقى]
مناقش الموضوع مع ضيفينا من موسكو السفير
نائب رئيس جمعيه
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق وكبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي
بايسكويت
في تلك المنطقه
على كل من الجانبين ان يحقق المكاسب
وبالتالي هذا سوف يمنحنا هامشا
للمفاوضات لان المعارك سوف تتغطى وحين ذلك
يصير السؤال المطروح ما هي الضمانات
الامنيه التي يمكننا ان نمنعها لروسيا بما
يحملها للعوده الوفاء المفاوضات وما الذي
يجب ان نفعله حتى نحمله اوكرانيا على
الاعتراف بان هذه الحرب لا يسعها
الاستمرار ولا يمكنهم استعاده
القرمباس التي اصلا لم تكن لدى اوكرانيا
حين بدات الحرب
هل تقاسم موسكو هذه القراءه للاستخبارات
الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بطباطؤ وطيئه القتال
او تباطئ وتيره القتال عفوا في اوكرانيا
لدينا نظره عن التقرير للمخابرات
الامريكيه
ينظر الى الاوضاع بشكل سيء وهم لا يعرفون
ما يحدث في الواقع ولا يعلمون العادات
والتقاليد للجيش الروسي لان ثلث التدريبات
المخطط لها في الجيش الروسي تمر في فصل
الشتاء لذلك
التغيرات في الطقس بالنسبه لانها
وللعمليات العسكريه لن تقوم باي تغييرات
ليس للمعدات العسكريه وليست للجنود لن
يكون هناك اي تغيرات نحن سوف ندير الاوضاع
بوجهه نظر اخرى مركزين على مختلف الواجهات
بالعمليات الخاصه بنا حتى نهايه همم كل
العمليه العسكريه بنجاح وهذا ما لا شك به
الجيش الروسي مهيء للقتال في اجواء مثل
الاجواء المقبله في فصل الشتاء يقول
السفير اندري هل ترى هذا واقعيا في طبيعه
الحرب باوكرانيا
الروسيه الاخيره حتى قبل بدء فصل الشيطان
كان
تقضي به قصف في البناء تحت
وتعطيني
التدفئه حتى يفقد الشعب الداعمه او اعتقد
الحكومه دعم الشعب وهذا اخطا اذا راينا
المعارك الباريه التي همم شنتها روسيا
حسبت انها ستسيطر على العاصمه ومن ثم
خيرسون ولكن
الى الانضمام الى روسيا من خلال الاستفتاء
ولكن هذا لم يحصل وبالتالي روسيا تخسر
وتقديرات تشير الى انه حوالي 100000 روسي
قد قتل ومئه
حاولوا اذا ان يحشدوا الاحتياطي بامئه او
راينا نتيجه لذلك 200 الف شخص يهربون من
البلاد اتوا باحتياطي لم يتدرب منذ سبع
سنوات او اكثر من ذلك وبالتالي يخسرون
المعارك يمكن هم ان يستمر في محاوله تدمير
اوكرانيا ولكن هذا لن يجعلهم يربحوا الحرب
حان الوقت حتى تدرك روسيا انها بحاجه الى
ان تعود على الاقل الى المرحله التي كانت
سبقت الحرب اذا كانت مقاربه الاستخبارات
الامريكيه خاطئه او سيئه كما وصفتها انت
بمفهوم موسكو اذا ما الرساله من هذه
التصريحات من الهند
ان في الواقع
المخابرات الامريكيه لديها معلومات
غير التي يعلن عنها بل معلومات مقلقه لهم
اكثر بكثير
وهذا يعني انه بالطبع هناك فتره في
المستقبل محوريه جدا
وعلينا ان نؤمن للجيش كل الظروف المطلوبه
ابني عسكري واريد ان اقول ان التجهيزات
الحقيقيه للجيش تحتاج الى سنتين من الحرب
ليس من التدريبات في ظروف سلميه بل من
الحرب
وعندها سوف نحضر الجيش لا ينهزم نحن
يتزايد لدينا المعدات المتطوره وعندها سوف
نتحدث بطريقه اخرى مع امريكا ومع اوروبا
نحن لا
سوف ننتصر في نهايه المعارك كما حدث هذا
في التاريخ مسبقا اما ال ااه ما يقدمون في
امريكا هذا كله يدل على ان لديهم معلومات
ضعيفه جدا ومحدوده او ان هذا بروفاكاندام
التي يجب علينا ان ندركها جيدا هل يمكن
لاي مبادره دبلوماسيه ان تنطلق بعيدا عن
شركاء الخندق في الحرب الدائره في
اوكرانيا الرئيس الفرنسي قال انه يعتزم
التحدث مع زلينسكي قبل اجراء محادثات
هاتفيه مع بوتن الرئيس مكروه اضاف قائلا
انتظرته الفرصه لمناقشه كل شيء بالتفصيل
مع بيضا قبل التحدث مع بوتين
اما المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
فقط قال انه لا يوجد موعد محدد بعد لاجراء
محادثات هاتفيه بين الرئيسين بوتين ومكروم
سيد لاريكول هل ترى صله ما بين تصريحات
ايفر الهندس وتصريحات الرئيس مكروه عن
اعطاء ضمانات امنيه لروسيا في حال قابلت
في بالتفاوض
الامريكيه كانت شغاله منذ البدايه وهي
التي قالت ان روسيا سوف تشرح اوكرانيا
بينما كان كثيرون يرفضون تصديق ذلك اذا
هذا المعلومات المعلومات الامريكيه موثوقه
اما بالنسبه الى ضمانات الامنيه التي
يسعنا اعطائها ان اوكرانيا لن يسمح لها
الانضمام الى حلفنيته في المستقبل القريب
المنظور يتحدث عن سبع سنوات
ولكن هذا نكته اساسيه يعني
اوكرانيا حين ذاك لن تعودته
في روسيا اما النقطه الاساسيه فيها هل
تقبل الجلوس 2014
كثيرا على تعويلات المفاوضات انا فعلا
اتمنى ان يكون نجل زميلي السفير باكلانوف
بخير ولكن في حقيقه الامر فائق قد قتل
وجريحه حوالي 200,000 جندي روسيه حتى الان
وانا لا اعتقد ان الشعب الروسي سوف يستمر
في دعم ذلك حين التقى رئيس بوتين بزوجات
الجنود لم يظهر ذلك لانها كثيره منهن كنا
قليقات واعربنا عن قلقهن على ابنائهن
وازواجهم
روسيا بالضمانات الامنيه او ها هو الرئيس
يطرح على الرئيس بوتين مبادره تتعلق
بالضمامات الامنيه هل ترى موسكو في في في
تصريحات الرئيس مكرونه فرصه للجلوس على
طاوله المفاوضات وانهاء الحرب
كلكم بكل صراحه في موسكو
ننظر الى كلمات السيد مايكرون والكثير من
القيادات الاوروبيه كاشخاص غير جديين
لاننا ونحن نتحدث معهم فقط من الادب
نحن نعتقد ان حديث جدي ممكن ان يكون مع
الولايات المتحده فقط لانها مهم من يقفوا
خلف كل هذه الاحداث ويديرونها
ااا ويديرون ال التراتيل الاوروبيه الذين
لا يستطيعون ان يفكر بطريقه حره او ان
يتصرفوا بحريه لذلك لا نرى اي فرص حقيقيه
في هذه الاعلانات التي يقوم بها مكرون اما
بالنسبه للجدول اليومي منذ سنه تحدثنا
للنته للولايات المتحده
وطلبنا منهم ان نتفق ان نجلس على طاوله
المفاوضات ونتحدث بالنسبه لكل المشاكل
العسكريه والسياسيه اليوم هذا شيء لم يعد
كافي اليوم لدينا
شروط ثلاثه اضافيه مهمه جدا ويجب ان نحلها
هذه المسائل ضمن المجموعه يجب ان ننزع
النظام النادي من اوكرانيا ويجب ان نقاضي
الاداره الاوكرانيه ثم نزع السلاح الجيش
الاوكراني حيث لا يبقى اي بقايا لاننيتو
او اي جنود قادرين ان يهددوا الامن الروسي
وشيء الثالث هو
حل جميع المشاكل
الانسانيه
وتطوير الدوله
وتحديد الاوضاع للحدود الاوكرانيه التي
اصبحت موجوده في هذا الوقت
بحسب السفير فان موسكو لا تعير هذه
التصريحات همم اهميه همم كبيره همم
باعتقادك ما الذي يمكن ان تحمله هذه
المبادره اذا صحت تعبير اذا صحت تسميتها
من الرئيس ماكرو الحديث عن ضمانات امنيه
ما الجديد الذي يمكن ان تحمله على المسار
السياسي للحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
اعتقد انه من المهم انه قال ذلك بعد ان
التقى الرئيس الامريكي ايضا لم يتحدث عن
ذلك
لا يمكن ان يضغط على
اوكرانيا
في العلن ولكنه يجلس ربما
الامور ويقول لا يمكن لاحد ان يسود على
الاخر روسيا خسرت عسكريا هل تستمر في او
هل يمكنها ان تستمر في تنميه المناسبه نعم
هذا ممكن ولكن ماذا تحقق من خلال ذلك يجب
ان ندرك انه يمكننا ان نحملها اوكرانا على
الجلوس الى طويله المفاوضات بالنظر الى كل
التجهيزات التي وفناها لهم اكثر من 100
مليار دولار من بالتالي
لكننا لا نريد للولايات المتحده لاسباب
سياسيه ان تخرج الى العمل همم
بايضا ضعيفه في مجال الدفاع وبالتالي حامل
ماكرون على قول ذلك بعد ان التقى بعيدا
يبعث بمؤشرا ورساله مفاده انا الولايات
المتحده مستعده للدعم مبادره الضمانات
الامنيه
وكلمه السر هنا هي انا اوكرانيا لن تنضم
الى حل جمع الاطلسي او اذا انضمت اليه لن
تشكل تحديدا عسكريا لروسيا
قال بان التصريحات تتضمن جوانب مختلفه بل
ان تصريحاته تتضمن جوال مختلفه ربما تكون
هي الوجه الاخر للرساله فبشان تقديم الدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا قال مكروه ان بلاده
ستواصل دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا وانها ستزود
اكياس بمزيد من الاسلحه
ساحاول ان اوضح الامر منذ بدايه النزاع
قررنا فعلا تقديم الدعم العسكري وهناك
دوما خطان لتحديد اجراءاتنا بطريقه بسيطه
جدا لن نضع ابدا قدره جيوشنا على حمايه
اراضينا وجنودنا ومواطنين ابدا والحدث
الثاني هو اننا لن نسلم ابدا اسلحه يمكنها
ان تورطنا في الصراع اي تسمح بمهاجمه
روسيا على ارضها قمنا ونستمر في القيام
بما هو في استطاعتنا اذا الاجابه هي نعم
سنسلم اسلحه اضافيه وسنطلب من مصانعنا
تسريع وتيره الانتاج لتسليم الطلبات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في ضوء امانتك
السفير اندريه اذا كما قال السيد لاريكور
بان هناك على ما يبدو تنسيق فرنسي امريكي
وممكن ان يدعم
مسار تفاوضي على اساس تلبيه الهواجس
الامنيه بالنسبه لروسيا لا يشكل هذا فرصه
نظرا للسيتيكو الحاصل على الارض
والتراجعات
للجيش الروسي والقوات المواليه له على
الارض في اوكرانيا
متخصص في الامور العسكريه والسياسيه لا
ارى فرصه لهذا
هو اعتقد ان المفاوضات الحقيقيه ممكن ان
يكون لها شكل اغاثي وهذا الموضوع مهم جدا
وايضا ممكن ان يكون هناك مفاوضات في
المسائل التي تخص الحبوب ومختلف المسائل
المهمه ولكن ليس الاهم المشتاق الاهم في
الوقت الحالي هي
شيء من الصعب حله
على الاقل لانه هناك
واقع جديد
لتوزيع الحدود وهذه مساله خلاف كبير بيننا
وبين الغرب هناك اربع قطاعات اصبحت روسيه
واعتقد ان هذه المساله
واي بروتين سوف نحاول ان نصل الى اعتراف
كامل بحقوقنا بهذه المناطق اما
همم اشك ان يكون هناك حوار ممكن ان يصل
الى النتيجه في هذه المسائل اذا سايكورب
سؤال اخير المنطق همم يقول بانه يجب
الاستعداد لاحتمالات اخرى منه التصعيد
مثلا خاصه بعد فصل الشتاء ما الذي يجب
مراقبته من الان حتى يتضح فعليا الموقف
الروسي همم من تصريحات الرئيس مكروه
واي فاي
نحن ايضا سوف نستمر وكل دول حل شمال
الاطلسي والولايات المتحده سوف توفر الى
اوكرانيا التجهيزات التي تحتاج اليها من
اجل ان تستمر في الفوز بالمعارك الميدانيه
يمكن لروسيا ان تدمر البناء تحتيها لا شك
في ذلك ولكن
هو كلما استمرت بذلك همم
عشان سافرت بخسارتي شبه جزيره القرم الى
السعاده
اوكرانيا خرسان فربما قد تتقدم الى جزيره
القرم وروسريكا احتمال خسارتها القرموها
اذا لم تجلس المفاوضات كلما استمرت الحرب
وطالت الحرب سوف تخسر روسيا عسكريا
الولايات المتحده في مجال الدعامه
نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس في
موسكو
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا المتابعه الى اللقاء
بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]